l'hospitalisation dé jacques chirac a
créé émotions et surprises à l'ump en
pleine université d'été une journée très
particulière à la baule sur place
michael d'armand laurent des mois
lorsque dominique de villepin transforme
sa séance quotidienne de sport en
séquence de communication politique le
chef du gouvernement pense surtout voix
affiché sa forme aux côtés du président
de l'ump nicolas sarkozy lui l'attend en
terrasse café-croissant devant les
caméras ce petit moment d'union sucré
entre les vrais faux rivaux de la droite
jusque là tout semble normal à la boule
mais de retour à son hôtel dominique de
villepin reçoit selon la version
officielle un coup de fil de jacques
chirac et lui annonce son
hospitalisation pour une semaine le chef
du gouvernement convoque de son côté la
presse comme vous le savez il a eu hier
soir un petit accident vasculaire ayant
entraîné un léger trouble de la vue qui
devraient se résorber au cours des
prochains jours
dès lors tout s'accélère nicolas sarkozy
qui ne seraient pas encore
officiellement au courant s'isole avec
le chef du gouvernement
à cet instant plusieurs 59 une dépêche
afp dans le communiqué conciliabules
entre les entourages c'est nicolas
sarkozy qui annonce camille vallaux
participants
je voudrais vous demander monsieur
dominique notre interprète à tous ici
pour souhaiter au président de la
république un prompt rétablissement pour
les nuls à la boule c'est l'émotion on
est très touché par ce qui arrive aux
prisons en république on espère qu'il va
se rétablir à séraphine se trouve que
j'ai eu l'occasion de rencontrer le
président de la khl des cuillères de
travailler avec lui dire après midi hier
en fin de matinée et il était
particulièrement particulièrement en
forme et les propos de dominique de
villepin ferait une autre dimension
27 ans j'avais une rencontre jacques
chirac et je lui ai volé une fidélité
jacques chirac le maître en politique de
dominique de villepin
acclamé par l'ump de nicolas sarkozy
deux rivales assurément la droite
chiraquienne aujourd'hui a vécu à la
baule une journée particulière